on va rester dans le sujet maintenant on
en parle avec la criminologue maria
mourani bonsoir madame hourani bonsoir
madame boulet alors vous êtes
spécialiste des gangs de rue aussi ça
fait 20 ans que vous intéresser toutes
ces questions procession d'abord
expliquer nos systèmes
ces coins-là ce réseau où on prend des
jeunes femmes québécoises et on les
balades en ontario on les amène dans
l'ouest comment ça fonctionne tout
d'abord il faut savoir que la traite des
personnes au canada la très très grande
majorité de la traite est interne
donc c'est vraiment des filles qu'on
balade d'une ville à l'autre d'une
province à l'autre parfois aussi vers
les états unis je vous dirais même assez
souvent vers les états unis
particulièrement miami new york
donc c'est très connu ça que la traite
des personnes au canada
ce sont des filles de chez nous qui vont
être balloté un peu partout dans ce qu
il faut savoir aussi c'est que ces
proxénètes là vont envoyer ses fils adam
des places où ils savent que la
clientèle veut ce genre de marchandise
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle dans le milieu des marchandises
donc il faut savoir que par exemple en
ontario les filles québécois sont très
prisés c'est ce que la clientèle
recherche et surtout ils font beaucoup
d'argent
les proxénètes la leur leur but premier
c'est de faire de l'argent c'est un
business
donc pour eux quand ils envoient en
ontario en une semaine ou deux semaines
elles peuvent faire le double de ce
qu'ils font ici au québec les policiers
ont mis l'accent sur la violence que ces
jeunes femmes ne subisse parlait
pratiquement de torture ici à un tel
point où elles n'osent plus dénoncés
elles sont aliénés parlez moi de leur
vulnérabilité
écoutez tout à fait moi je peux vous
dire qu'en 20 ans j'ai rencontré
énormément de filles qui ont été
victimes de traite et ce sont des
violences tellement énorme je peux vous
parler de torture de menaces de mort de
menacer la femme a pris le père la mère
de dire que si tu fais parce que je veux
ça va être ta soeur ça est ton frère
menace même physique dans le sens
qu'elles sont battus viol collectif
passage elle peut avoir à passer 15 à 20
clients donc énormément de violence qui
font en sorte que ces filles là ça leur
prend des années pour sortir de leur
stress post traumatique et beaucoup
d'entre elles n'en sortent jamais est-ce
que ça explique pourquoi c'est pas si
fréquent de voir ses victimes qui sont
sortis de leur province qui se retrouve
isolé dans un endroit qu'elles ne
connaissent pas elles demandent peu
souvent à l'aide
elles vont peu souvent chercher l'aide
des policiers ou dénoncer leur agresseur
c'est la paresse parce qu'elles sont
brisés qu'elles ne le font pas oui tout
à fait c'est la peur d'abord et avant
tout c'est la peur c'est sûr que vous
avez une autre catégorie de filles qui
sont amoureuses donc en fait il ya deux
grands facteurs l'amour et la peur mais
parfois lorsque l'amour est là va se
transformer en peur parce que il pourra
pas toujours la maintenir dans la
relation amoureuse
là comme une phase si vous voulez de
ligne demierre et après ça c'est la
chute aux enfers dont kung fu le premier
élément qui les maintient qui fait en
sorte qu'elle ne dénonce pas qu'elles ne
vont pas parlé à la famille qu'elles
vont être totalement isolé
si la peur mais une peur qui vous en
chaîne à l'intérieur c'est à dire ces
femmes là sont en chine et vous ne voyez
pas leurs chaînes leur chalet son
intérieur et elles sont puissantes parce
que elles vont même avoir des stress
post traumatique et parfois même ce
qu'on n'a pas le syndrome de stockholm
est bon on arrivait à tomber amoureuse
un agresseur ce qui peut paraître assez
aberrant pour quelqu'un qui est de
l'extérieur mais ça c'est leur réalité
donc je sais c'est juste survivre et
même oui mais non c'est une question de
survie parce que c'est soit je meurs pas
ce que vous imaginez vous que tous les
jours ces femmes-là entendent de leur
proxénète
si tu fais pas ce que je veux je vais te
tuer donc à l'intérieur d'elle-même
elles ont l'impression et ce n'est pas
une impression c'est une réalité
qu'elles peuvent mourir n'importe quoi
elles peuvent disparaître comme ça
n'importe quand il y en a qui ont
disparu y en a qui en a qu'on a plus
revus et on pourrait parler des femmes
autochtones disparues et assassinées on
pourrait parler d'autres personnes qui
ont pu disparaître
ouais effectivement vous avez raison
vous touche à quelque chose ici il ya
toutes celles qu'on ne retrouvera
mais dans nos plus une nouvelle paraît
mois de l'importance de ce coup de filet
aujourd'hui c'est 31 arrestations
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va avoir
un impact sur les réseaux écoutez moi ce
que je trouve intéressant aujourd'hui
dans cette arrestation là c'est qu'on
voit qu'il ya une espèce de
d'organigramme c'est bien organisé que
la police a assez de preuves pour
pouvoir porter des accusations de
gangstérisme
ce qui est très intéressant par contre
ce que moi je suis très curieuse de voir
qu'est ce qui va se passer en cours avec
justement les deux dispositions de la
loi sur le renversement de la preuve et
sur la confiscation de des fruits de la
criminalité qui a été mis en place cet
été
je remercie les élections monsieur
trudeau a fait en sorte après quatre ans
à ne rien faire finalement il a mis ça
en application moi je suis très curieuse
de voir comment les procureurs vont
utiliser sans cours parce que maintenant
lorsqu'il ya des accusations de traite
bien automatiquement un renversement du
fardeau de la preuve
ce qui va être beaucoup plus facile
d'accuser de condamner ces gars là mais
en plus de ça la confiscation des fruits
de la criminalité va faire en sorte
qu'ils ne pourront plus bénéficier de
leurs biens s'ils sont reconnus
coupables
alors j'ai bien hâte de voir comment ça
va tourner en cour de justice
toute cette belle opération mais alors
ça sera un test effectivement et on
verra parce qu'effectivement ça votre
contribution à ce projet de loi pour
changer les règles pour essayer
finalement de mettre un frein à ce
produit mais si ce qui était un cancer
de société on le voit bien avec ce que
vous avez décrivez madame mourani merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue grand
plaisir madame boulet au revoir